police investigating a possible hate
crime against actor Jesse Smollett are
asking the public for help
Smollett is best known for the TV drama
Empire he claims he was attacked on a
Chicago Street by two men who wrapped a
rope around his neck Dean Rollins has
spoken with officers searching for
evidence to back up smollett's
allegations dean good morning good
morning Smollett plays Jamal Lyon on the
hit show Empire which is filmed here at
a studio in Chicago the FBI has also
joined this inquiry now but so far
investigators have been unable to
release a description of the alleged
assailants Jessie small add who plays a
game musician on the Fox hit show Empire
and identifies as gay in real life says
he was beaten by two masked men who
shattered racist epithets gay slurs and
put a noose around his neck a police
dispatcher had the barest of details on
the early morning attack which was
reported by small Ed's business manager
when police got to his apartment they
said a noose was still around smollett's
neck he told them he was also doused
with an unknown chemical and officer
said they smelled bleach on his clothes
in a now-deleted Instagram post by
Empire co-creator Lee Daniels small that
appeared to have an abrasion on his
cheek you didn't deserve no anybody
deserves to have a news put around your
neck to have bleach thrown on you
police say in a subsequent meeting
Smollett added that his assailants
reference president Trump's campaign
slogan make America great again during
the attack 12 detectives and a number of
FBI agents are now investigating what
has been classified as a possible hate
crime but sources say they have seen
security video of smollett outdoors
early Tuesday morning
and nothing of an assault detectives
have expanded the search area for video
of the alleged assailants but have not
found any footage or witnesses SMO let's
Empire co-star vivica a fox tweeted I'm
so angry and heard about this
California Senator Kamala Harris a 2020
presidential
it called the attack and attempted
modern day lynching in a statement 20
20th Century Fox television and Fox
Entertainment said they were deeply
saddened and outraged by the despicable
act of violence and hate
yesterday Smollett went to the hospital
was evaluated and released biana team
thank you and CBS will continue to
follow this story